[Applause]
this walkout at Saint brother Andre and
Markham was intended as an opportunity
to support 2s lgbtq plus students at a
time where the York Catholic board has
ruled to not raise the pride flag for
pride month everyone has the right to
love who they want to love it's weird
that they're prioritizing the comfort of
the parents rather than the safety of
the students
but messages like this were quickly
drowned out by the noise of a rowdy
crowd
students tearing through Pride posters
and dancing on Pride Flags it's rude and
they're throwing water everywhere
they're looking at us they're judging us
shouldn't be like that you're out for a
reason rambunctious teens then turned
violent throwing Pride bracelets and
other random objects on the road and at
people some kid threw something at my
head and then in response to that
everyone started cheering there was like
a group of guys and
they were more like harassing us than
supporting us organizers say the
disruptive group also shouted anti-queer
slurs I just wish that there was a lot
more positivity and love and support
right now advocacy organization pflake
who deemed the York Catholic District
School Board unsafe for two S lgbtq Plus
students says the Board needs to be held
accountable for Thursday's events if
these kids are the type of culture that
is creating the culture of hate and
discrimination and bigotry and bigotry
at uh you're Catholic than the Catholic
School Board has an urgent need to act
and to act now the ycdsb Tells global
news that it is aware of an assault on a
student that took place during that
walkout here at Saint brother Andre and
that police are currently Gathering
video footage as part of their
investigation Brittany Rose in Global
News Marco